all right uh it's been a really long day
I played two really hard fall games
today the first game I played today was
super long as you can see by the
notation uh let me hide it just to avoid
any spoiler but um yeah I didn't have
time to record a recap after this game
because I had to quickly eat lunch and
then prepare for my next one so I think
what I'll do is record both Recaps uh
right now but I'll have them in separate
videos so uh for this one uh I'll share
the game I played against Jacob templin
grave Canon master from Norway and
um he's actually uh I think a long time
viewer of my content he told me after
the game that he's been watching for
many years and we've played a decent
amount online actually I found his uh
his leeches accounts uh yesterday in
preparation for this game and we've
played I think about 10 times so I knew
going into the game that he's a pretty
avid Carole Khan player and I prepared a
really tricky line
um starting with two nights attack
now I do have a video on YouTube called
how to crush the Carol Kong in which I
recommend the two nights attack and to a
lot of like cool tricks and traps but uh
the line that we went into in this game
is a very deep sort of Gambit and it
starts with the main Theory H3 takes
takes this is all very standard Bishop
E2 Main Line E6 castle and there's
different ways the position can Branch
out uh black could take black could play
knight t7 uh but he played I think
what's the most
um there's a second most common move
Bishop to C5
but very logical move
um just developing and preventing me
from playing Pawn D4 so I was still in
prep and I played the move Rook to D1
preparing Pawn D4 to try and get Tempo
on the bishop and then he blitzed out
Bishop to D4
and I knew that he's had this position
before online and I had this position on
my computer right before the game and I
Was preparing uh what I played in the
game Queen to F4
and at first this looks like a slightly
mysterious move because okay what is the
queen doing on F4 but I'm aligning with
the bishop and I'm threatening to either
play E5 or take on D5 and hit the bishop
and if black plays Pawn E5 I can simply
move back and hit G7 and there's some
argument that E5 uh loosens the center a
little bit for black
so after Queen F4
um he took the Knight and I'm actually
losing a pawn here because after he
takes takes white is now down upon but
again this is all pre-game prep uh in
compensation for being down upon I have
the bishop pair and I have a bit of
initiative especially after my next move
Rook to B1
and I knew that he had this position
once online and he encountered Bishop to
A3 which is other um kind of main option
for whites but Rook B1 is a top engine
move and for about maybe an hour before
the game I was reviewing a lot of the
engine lines from this position and
stockfish will give a slight Plus for
whites but the position is very
complicated and it's hard to understand
a lot of lines require accurate play now
the sad thing which happened here is he
played a move that I did not look at
beforehand I was prepared for Queen E7
Pawn B5 and queen D6 thought these were
the the main three moves and I had
pretty extensive preparation against
each of these moves but he played a
logical looking move which for some
reason I didn't look at it but it says
puns a B6 and um I was just upset with
myself uh when he played this because I
should have at least looked at this uh
before the game now it does seem like
Pawn B6 is very similar to pawn B5 but
there are some small nuances against
Pawn B5
I had a cool line prepared which I'll
just go ahead and show is Bishop A3
Queen F6 and then Queen C7 losing F2 but
after King to H1 white threatening mates
and uh I think White's already
substantially better because Knight D7
would be forest and I take and then B5
is hanging
um but unfortunately with Pawn to B6
that's what happened in the game uh he
has some additional options after I play
Bishop A3 he right away plays C5 doesn't
go for Queen F6 but just blocks my
Bishop on A3 and I was on my own here
um but I knew some of the kind of
standard plans generally white wants to
try and open the position with either C4
or Pawn D4 I also knew another very
common idea the move I ended up playing
is Bishop to F3 just challenging the
Knight on e4 now it turns out that
Bishop F3 was a small all mistake what I
should have done was recognize that even
though black has closed off one diagonal
another diagonal is open and there's
only sequence here which I did check
after the game is Bishop to B5 forcing
Knight D7 and then C4 really nice move
um and even though blackouts to Castle
there's takes takes in Bishop T6 and I
probably should have at least been aware
of this during the game and maybe if I
saw this idea like combining Bishop E5
and C4 uh perhaps I would have went for
it
but um didn't go into that I played
Bishop F3 because in a lot of other
lines I was looking at before the game
Bishop F3 was one of the main moves and
it makes sense just aligning a lot of
things on the long diagonal but then he
plays Knight G5 and it gets a little bit
awkward even though the Knight looks
weird on G5 he just wants to simplify
and then get rid of my Bishop so from
here I um I leave the bishop on F3 and
play D4 trying to create some
distraction and I really want to make my
Bishop on A3 useful so D4 is a way to do
that but then he plays Queen F6 and then
from here things start getting pretty
concrete I have to respond to this move
of course my Queen's attacks and I was
thinking that if I moved back then he
would just take and my structure would
be ruined so I decided to trade Queens
and even though I'm still down a pawn
um I thought there's still compensation
because I have this move Bishop to H5
and this is a weird looking Square for
the bishop but I had ideas of later
playing Rook E1 and then exploiting the
fact that athpan is pinned and the dream
is to eventually capture on E6 but as
we're gonna see things get a little bit
messy after Knight to E4 uh threatening
to take on C3 and Fort my Rooks I play
rookie one leave the C Pawn hanging
um and he didn't take it just to show if
he does take it then I would play Rook
B3
if I take right away I don't think this
works because King D7 but my plan was
Rook B3 and when the Knight moves I play
F3 and light moves to the fend the pawn
I play H4 and just trap the Knight so
I'm pretty sure the pawn on C3 is poison
and yeah for that reason he played
Knights to D7 which I think was a very
useful move just salute defying C5 and
from here I still went ahead and played
F3 trying to create play on the e-file
but then after Knight D2 Rook D1 Knight
C4 he was able to optimize Knights and
still make threats this time attacking
the bishop
after I moved back then he castled now
one thing I want to share before we go
forward in the game I was considering a
crazy line here Pawn takes C5
sacrificing the bishop
but during the game I I couldn't make it
work like after takes I wanted to go for
this takes and I have King f8 I would
play this hitting the Knight and if my
takes and this is kind of what I was
calculating and white is winning another
Pawn here because these two pawns are
hanging but I didn't think there was
enough compensation for the piece
um let me check real quick with the
engine because I'm curious
is this playable for whites nah Black is
Black is for choice
we go back even further
oh that's interesting
the engine just says
uh for a moment counseling was a top
move but Knight A3 also much better for
black I haven't checked this game
extensively with engine so there are
some moments where
um I'm very curious to see what
stockfish will say
so let me show what happened uh Bishop
C1 was played and then he castled and
for some reason I like when I had
calculated to this line Bishop C1 and
castling I thought that black
could be in trouble here because of the
idea Bishop H6 Rook moves and now white
has a plan of lifting The Rook over to
G3 and because the king can't move back
to the center there are situations where
this can be very bad for lack also the
king is tied down to defending Athan so
when I saw this position from a distance
I thought it seems like white has good
chances
oh man my voice is dry let me get some
water I'll be right back
what was I saying oh yeah so it seems
like in this position white has good
chances uh even though I'm still down a
pawn but then the more I thought the
more I realized that I'm actually in
some trouble here uh because black has a
very strong idea Knight D6 to F5 and I
just don't have time to get my Rook to
G3 because when the Knight comes F5 not
only does it prevent Rook G3 but it hits
the bishop and at this moment I realized
my Gambit went terribly wrong because
I'm down a pawn and I didn't really see
any compensation
so around here I think I played F4 and
offered a draw
um because I realized the position is
about to get really bad and
um yeah he immediately just declined the
draw and played Knight D6 and uh now
yeah my Bishops look a little bit
ridiculous
um I I saw a comment in the leeches chat
after the game saying why would you why
would you like tr get the bishop pair
for two nights and then just put the
Bishops on the edge of the board where
they do nothing and it was really a
result of misjudgment and um not
realizing that my attack just doesn't
work but I didn't want to give up and I
at this point I really wanted to make
the position as messy as possible
so I went ahead and played Pawn into G4
and uh it's ugly because I'm blocking
both my Bishops now they're both stuck
but I do prevent Knight F5
and I have ideas of playing F5 or G5 and
there are still dreams of bringing the
Rook to G2 playing G5 taking and then
doing some windmill checkmates but it
was very far off in uh in fantasy world
so things continue From Here pawn Jakes
pawn and then I play Pawn F5 just trying
to make things crazy and we can see that
by this time stamps I'm a bit lower on
time but still okay we both have enough
time like we're not in severe time
pressure just yet
and then he actually took a long time
here he took 18 minutes to play Knight
to E4 but I think this is a really good
move because it just establishes a
really strong outpost on e4 blocks my
Rook essentially depends upon and yeah
he's taking his time before capturing a
Pawn on the C file on top of everything
he has ideas of Knight G3 so I was not
feeling good here I took on D4 and then
he plays 95. and we can see here that
the knights are just so much better than
the Bishops my Bishop's just on the edge
knights in the center he's threatening a
triple Fork my C Pawn is hanging
multiple ways but I still had hope and I
played Pawn to G5 which both defends the
F3 squares so preventing the triple fork
and also just trying to bust things open
on the G file and get some sort of
counter play
and then he takes on C3 I play H4 and
actually when he takes on C3 this is a
massive threat and at this point I
thought I was just on the verge of
losing H4 was kind of a last-ditch
effort to not get skewered on the H file
but then he plays Rook H3 anyway and I
still have problems uh with my my things
on the H file so I went ahead and took a
Pawn on E6 trying to uh to just open the
center a little bit and then he
surprised me instead of taking back on
E6 which I think is uh
um probably the most natural and
probably one of the best moves he took
the pawn on H4 and at first this looks
fine for a block because it hits a
bishop on H5 but I think he missed my
resource in this position I don't
actually have to take the pawn on F7 I
mean he was probably calculating takes
takes takes takes and then my Bishop
gets stuck on H6 in the very end but
after Rook H4 this allows Pawn to seven
and I'm essentially saying oh no my
Bishop but I'm getting a really strong
Pawn that's on the verge of promoting
because next move I want to take which
would simultaneously threaten rook d8
and taking the knights
so he told me after the game that at
some point in this recap I should
mention the the phrase grave mistake
because he has a grave in his name so I
think Rook H4 Rook takes H4 was a very
grave mistake
um and actually I think just lost most
of the advantage but after Pawn E7 the
game is really just beginning and we're
not even close to to the whole story of
this game so let's go forward uh he
plays Knight C6 and I'm still on the
back foot because my Rook is hit my Pawn
is hanging my Bishop is hanging it still
looks not so great for whites but after
takes takes I play Rook to D7 and I'm
just in time to counter attack and I'm
able to leave my Bishop hanging and then
all of a sudden there's threats on uh
against both nights and there's also
pressure against F7 so I was feeling
like I'm I'm on the verge of just coming
back here but then he found a I think a
nice way to keep an advantage after it
takes I take on e4 and then he takes on
G5
and for some reason during the game I
did not
consider this move I mean we're already
like both pretty low on time I was
anticipating this move Knight to F5 and
there's actually a funny line here
um I think Knight of five
is not a good move because it allows
Rook takes A7 and uh if he takes the
Rook then I made him on the back rink
and if he moves his Rook my plan was
actually just to keep attacking his Rook
if Rook d8
um Rook D7 if Rook C8 Rook C7 and I
thought this would be a funny way to
draw just keep harassing the rook and
The Rook can't really access these two
squares so I think this is just a draw
but yeah we didn't go into that because
he took on G5
and I think I didn't realize how
dangerous this move still was because
after takes takes takes it looks like
I'm out of danger even though I'm still
town to pawns my Rooks are hyper active
on the seventh rank
um but black is still able to play for
when here because I don't have Perpetual
uh the regards H7
so he plays A5 and it's not easy to win
Queen side pawns because they're they're
defended so I went ahead and played Rook
G7 he played King h8 and I was falling
really low on time I think I took a lot
of time on my next move because I really
wanted to keep my Rooks on the seventh
but the problem is if I just play a
waiting move like let's say King G2 he's
ready to play Rook G8 and if I keep my
Rooks as is then he starts pushing and
this Rook is actually really useful
helping
um guide the g-pawn I think I would be
in trouble here
sorry I'm getting a call uh uh let me
turn down this call and um and finish
the recap first sorry friend who's
calling me but um yeah let me show what
happens uh so I realize that Rook Gates
a threat and if I want to take the
g-pawn now is my only chance I take on
G5 but this allows Rook G8 and he trades
off a pair of Rooks and now it's black
only one who can play for a win um up a
clean Pawn
um and then I play Rook B7 I wanted to
keep the king cut off on the eighth rank
he plays Rook C6 I play A3 and around
here I thought it was going to be an
easy draw because after he takes I don't
have to take immediately if I take
immediately he wins this pawn and then
I'm gonna be down to pawns but I I
realize I have a very clever move here
Rook be a chuck
and the King doesn't really have great
shelter for King F7 I check again and
the King will either have to move up to
the sixth Rank and then I take the pawn
with check or he moves towards my rook
and then I can consider taking on H7
so what happened is after King two E8 I
decided first to take on B6 and after
Rook C3 I am losing the pawn but I'm
winning the H Pawn so at this point I
thought it was going to be an easy draw
but man was I wrong because after takes
I play King F2 I'm taking
um taking time before I I take back the
pawn because I want to get my king to
stop a pawn and then after A4
King E2
Rook A1
King D2
uh we got to a position
which I should note I was super low on
time so I was pretty sure in the moment
this is drawn but King D2 was actually a
very grave mistake and it allows black a
really beautiful winning idea here which
he did Miss in the game uh he played
Pawnee three the winning move for black
I believe it's only one winning move is
to play Rook G1
an idea is
if I take the pawn
if I don't take the pawn and move the
king my Rook is gonna go to G7 and then
A7 and then that will be winning for
black so pretty much I have to take the
pawn my last chance
and then he plays
A3 and when I try and stop a pawn A2
happens
and he's threatening to Queen I can't
take it because Rook G2 and my king is
just far away enough where this is
losing for white
and if I try to stop it with the King
just again A2 and A1 is coming
so
there was a missed opportunity for black
when I played King D2 and interestingly
enough the only drawing move as far as I
I know here is King D3
uh getting the king off the second Rank
and now if Rook G1 I can go into the
same line Rook H7 A3 Rook here and
there's not the same skewer trick
because my king is not on the second
Rank and this would be a draw
um now I'm not threatening to take the
pawn right away but I just want to play
King C2 and if A2 then I take
so I hope that makes sense Google is to
show that even the very simplified end
games like this can still be fairly
complex and even title players can make
very crave mistakes in these end games
so let me show what happened in the game
because it's still really just heating
up
um Rook G1 was a missed win or A3 was
missed when he should have played Rook
G1
and I played King to C2
and again at this point I thought it was
going to be a draw but then he plays A2
King B2
and then he plays Rook B1 and I'm I'm
realizing that I have to take the pawn
otherwise he queens and then Rook B7 my
king is cut off it's as far away from
his past Pawn as it can be and he's
ready to try and harass my rook and
start pushing the pawn
and at this point I still felt like
there was enough for white to draw but I
wasn't sure
uh so let me just show what happens I
played King A3 just waiting he moves to
f8
I was anticipating King G7 so I moved
back he plays King G7 you give a check
we repeat a little bit and then he plays
King to h8 so he still wants to advance
the pawn
I stop it from advancing
and then we do a little bit more dancing
and then he plays this move and this is
actually a really nice move because
uh he has a plan of King G7 check King
comes up I keep checking
and then when I when I attack the pawn
again his Rook is ready to come behind
and uh at this point I thought I was in
trouble because my king is so far away
and his King is actually in good
position to harass my rook and it looks
like his Pawn is going to come down and
it seems like I'm not in in time but
um yeah let me show what happens I play
Rook H6 I blockade the pawn uh the only
way for him to remove my Rook is to go
back to G5 with King and now I have time
to run back and now it's a race I really
want to get my king as close as possible
uh before he starts pushing so he plays
King G5 I move back plays H5 I run with
my king or walk with my king only so
much you can do move by move King G4
King D2 King F3 and he's trying to
shoulder me out and now if I play this
move
wait did I play that move no I give a
check if I play this move
I thought that each four would happen if
I come back
I wasn't sure what was happening here
like I was terrified of something like
this where
um maybe it's still a draw I don't know
anyway I didn't play King E1 I give a
check he plays King G2 and I move backs
and I'm trying to check from behind and
he plays H4 I check
I check
keep checking
and at this point the only shelter for
the king is in front of the pawn
and once he moves in front of the pawn I
was just kind of breathing a sigh of
relief because my king can come in and
um I start here with Rook F7 ensuring
that when I move my king to that file
there is no checks to chase me away
after Rook to G8 I play King F2 and then
he plays H2 and I play King F1
and um then actually something
interesting happened at the very end
because he offered me a draw here
but usually the the proper way to offer
a draw
is you make a move and then offer the
draw but he offered me a draw and his
clock was still ticking and I I didn't
want to accept it
um even though like okay I can't really
win this but um the reason why I didn't
want to accept it is because there's a
funnier way to draw this which I was
upset he didn't do and eventually I just
took his draw off her even though
um it was still his turn but um the the
funniest way to draw this position is
for black to play Rook G1 King F2 and
then Rook F1 and then say oh no my rook
and then stalemate so it could have
finished like this uh this was the final
position the game was a draw and yeah I
don't know what to make of this game I
think there were a lot of grave mistakes
throughout the game
um especially in the end game
um if I had more time probably at some
points in in the future I'm gonna have
to sit down and just learn all these
table based positions
um oh
black was winning with H4
so one cool thing about leechas any
position with seven pieces or less uh is
basically solved and you can ask table
base what the um what the wins are what
the valuation is
so anyway uh I think this recap is
almost at the half hour Mark
um if you want to analyze this game on
your own or any of my games I will leave
a link in the description to the live
broadcast where you can see all the
games from this tournament
um but I'm I'm tired uh this is such a
long game I still have one more recap to
record for today
um so thanks for watching uh oh one more
thing I wanted to promote the merch I
was wearing this hoodie during the game
and he was wearing a chess bra hoodie
and I realized during the game I should
run a sale for Merch so if you're
watching this within the first within
like the first week of it being uploaded
you can use coupon code Norway for 15
off all oh no my queen merch and
everything in the merch store I'll leave
a link in the description if you've been
enjoying these Recaps uh maybe get
yourself a hoodie or maybe get yourself
thank you
a shirts hopefully I remember to not
edit in the almost taking off all my
clothes but uh okay thanks for watching
and I'll see you guys in the next recap